The Joe Rogan Experience I wonder what
the percentage of like success rate
marriage is going to be in about five
years that's a really good question
because I was watching uh YouTube the
other day and a clip popped up that I
didn't watch but it was Lex Friedman had
some guy on and the guy was explaining
how Instagram is essentially uh an
infidelity accelerating machine because
if you think of like how many I mean I
know guys who are married and their
wife's page is all their wife sticking
their titties out and sticking their
butt out I mean it's literally the whole
page it's like these girls and I'm not
talking about girls who are like
professional Fitness influencers they're
not just showing how good their body is
I'm just talking about just regular gals
like if you're a professional Fitness
person and you know maybe you train
people or something like that yeah of
course you should show your body that's
what everybody wants yeah you're
literally advertising but look I did
this to me
I can help you do this to you but some
of them are just just ass and titties
and like do you what do you like my feet
and like they're married right so you
know they're getting bombed on in the
DMs like constantly and if something
goes wrong in the marriage they have
like probably so many options like pro
athletes are dming them and who knows
you know God same with the guys too how
easily those relationships are just
available what I was talking about that
last night with the dating apps like
when someone uh in one of those uh
bottom of the barrel shows one of the
questions was hinge which was a dating
app and I was like how much are you
going to be invested in trying to figure
somebody out if you've got like a
hundred people that you swiped on that
are also ready to go and you could just
like leave the state sucks like text
this person like hey
um something just came up I just got out
of a meeting dude do you want to go have
a late drink and then you go meet that
person like are we're trying again and
then if you're really that person that's
like it's got to be addictive like
everything else on social media is
addictive yeah so and addicted to just
meeting people and just swiping and they
all look hot like let's [__] go yeah
it's dangerous I mean marriage is such a
tough crazy thing do you know a lot of
people have successful marriages
I know people that have successful
marriages I wouldn't say I know a lot I
think look what is the divorce rate we
know 40 something percent I think it's
higher I think the national divorce rate
is close to 50 Chris Rock always had a
great bit about that he goes he goes and
that's just the people that have the
courage to get out how many cowards uh
that's the day and suffer especially
when they have kids and they're just
stay together being miserable with kids
and and they don't even know those kids
are sitting there looking at how they
interact with each other it's just
affecting them they just feel the
interactions if it's not genuine yeah
she's just there for the kids like [__]
yeah they feel like a bitterness between
them and then also they'll identify
future relationships like that too you
know that's like a scary thing about
people who grow up in like abusive
households like if the mother and father
are abusive to each other and verbally
abusive to each other then they'll
probably pattern that as they get older
and they they just think you're supposed
to like fight and then make up fight and
then make up and then people get caught
up in that cycle of fighting in makeup
because it feels good to make up you
know and the makeup sex is amazing but
the fighting part is just like people
get brutal they insult each other and
break each other down yeah it's like
yeah we're so lucky because I've been
with my girl almost 13 years now and
you've been with Danny for almost 10.
yeah but I bet being like the star you
are now trying to find a chick that I
mean the guys that are stars trying to
find actual love yeah because that's
possible I think it's probably easier if
you're a guy to find a good girl then
you're a girl to find a good guy
well yeah I would think so because like
I mean just to be sexist and to talk in
sexist terms women think of a man as a
provider like so you want a guy who can
keep it together right you want a guy
who you're going to have children you're
going to want a guy who's going to be
able to keep it together financially be
stable be disciplined do all things he's
going to do not fall apart not become a
drug addict not [__] do something
really stupid and lose his job and not
like just give up because of that and
then everybody gets on welfare like you
have to like count on someone unless you
want to work yourself so there's this
like evolutionary aspect and I think
it's hard like if you're a guy what do
you want out of a woman
I want her to be nice
all the physical things but you wanted
to be a good person a nice person I
don't need him to be successful yeah
like no God cares I do not care at all
like I would not care at all like if I
was a single guy and I met a gal and she
was like a bartender I did win like oh
just a bartender yeah okay good point
you know how many businesses like no one
cares no one cares like are you nice are
you nice are you cool you're fun to be
with do I enjoy spending time with you
then who cares so but but a woman like
Taylor Swift is not going to marry a
bartender all right it's [__] so true
[__] get the [__] out of here I sell
out stadiums yeah what do you do you
make drinks well that's why she's
talking with what that Travis Kelsey guy
though I can gotta do something big time
that's a good point thought about that
yeah who knows it's uh it's a TIF I
think it's a tougher Road for a woman to
find a good man that's what I think yeah
if I'm guessing because I don't know
that many good men I know a lot of cool
women yeah in terms of like the all
overall number of men that I know like
how many of them are going for it yeah
I'm lucky I know a lot of cool people
yeah I meet a lot of cool people but
just like General folks like how many of
these General folks are keeping it
together lazy fox a lot of lazy [__]